nu avec un recul d'environ 15% du taux
d'incidence sur la semaine écoulée mais
aussi du nombre de patients hospitalisés
en soins critiques dans notre pays pour
la première fois depuis début juillet le
taux d'incidence national est passé sous
la barre des 50 pour cent mille
habitants est une bonne nouvelle autre
bonne nouvelle aux antilles la situation
continue de s'améliorer nettement grâce
aux mesures de freinage qui ont été
mises en place grâce à la responsabilité
des habitants si cette baisse se
poursuit une nouvelle phase du
déconfinement pourra débuter très
prochainement nous restons donc sur la
bonne voie et nous pouvons aborder
l'automne sereinement dès lundi dans 47
départements nous avons pu alléger le
protocole sanitaire à l'école en
retirant notamment l'obligation du port
du masque pour les élèves et vous avez
vu qu'aux journal officiel aujourd'hui a
été publié une liste de nouveaux
départements qui à compter de lundi
prochain pourront donc basculé en
protocole numéro un dans l'éducation
nationale c'est à dire que dans ce
département également le masque pourra
être retiré pour les élèves c'est une
bonne nouvelle pour nos élèves qui
depuis plus d'un an avaient l'obligation
du port du masque et on sait combien
c'est contraignant notamment pour les
plus jeunes enfants
pour autant nous devons la vérité aux
français l'heure de lever toutes les
mesures toutes les contraintes n'est pas
venu dans près d'une trentaine de
départements l'épidémie ne recule plus
nous sommes tombés à un niveau très bas
mais ne recule plus voir repart très
légèrement à la hausse sans nous alerter
outre mesure à ce stade plusieurs
situation interpelle notamment dans
plusieurs départements de la région pays
de loire ou encore dans le département
de l'aude notre vigilance doit rester
total nous savons que le virus m l'hiver
et que le froid arrive par ailleurs
l'accalmie est loin d'être totale sur
l'ensemble du territoire national la
guyane demeure un point d' alerte
majeure le taux d'incidence s'installe
sur un plateau extrêmement élevé proche
de 500 pour 100000 habitants et le taux
de couverture vaccinale reste
désespérément faible des renforts
continuent d'arriver sur place et une
dizaine d'évacuations sanitaires ont eu
lieu ces derniers jours et nous
prévoyons la mobilisation du service de
santé des armées en juillet à nouveau
nous appelons les habitants à se faire
vacciner à se faire vacciner massivement
et rapidement
c'est la seule voie pour sortir la
guyane de cette quatrième vague
dévastatrice comme nous l'avons fait sur
l'ensemble du territoire enfin sur le co
vite je peux revenir sur la campagne de
rappel vaccinal le conseil de défense
qui s'est tenue ce matin a décidé de
suivre la recommandation de la haute
autorité de santé l'avis de la haute
autorité de santé qui autorise la
campagne de rappel vaccinal pour nos
personnels soignants vous souvenez que
nos personnels soignants était parmi les
premiers public à pouvoir se faire
vacciner au début de la campagne de
vaccination c'est normal il le fréquente
au quotidien des personnes malades et
sont donc exposés eux mêmes à la maladie
est par ailleurs ces personnes sont bien
souvent fragiles et donc s'ils sont eux
mêmes contaminées ils font évidemment
peser un risque sur leurs patients et
donc pour ces raisons la haute autorité
de santé a recommandé que la campagne de
rappel vaccinal leur soit ouverte et
donc nous avons décidé de suivre cet
avis dès aujourd'hui donc les soignants
qui sont complètement vaccinés qui avait
un schéma vaccinal complet depuis plus
de six mois peuvent recourir au rappel
vaccinal nous les invitons évidemment à
le faire ils sont d'ailleurs très
nombreux ces derniers jours ces
dernières semaines à avoir émis le
souhait de pouvoir recourir au rappel
dès aujourd'hui ceux qui sont éligibles
qui sont concernés peuvent prendre
rendez-vous dans un centre de
vaccination dans une pharmacie chez un
médecin libéral pour se faire vacciner
c'est près de 3 millions de soignants
qui sont donc concernés par cette
ouverture de la campagne de rappel
vaccinal je veux à cette occasion comme
j'ai eu l'occasion de le faire la
semaine dernière relancé un appel pour
les personnes qui sont d'ores et déjà
éligibles rappel vaccinal à y recourir
vous le savez nous avons ouvert depuis
le début du mois de septembre la
campagne de rappel pour les personnes de
plus de 65 ans et pour les personnes qui
ont une fragilité particulière vis-à-vis
de la maladie cette campagne de rappel a
démarré elle s'amplifie mais elles
restent à un rythme insuffisant et je
veux redire que nous appelons toutes
celles et ceux qui sont concernés à y
recourir c'est un rappel très important
pour maintenir l'immunité qui est
conféré le vaccin auprès des personnes
confère concernés il faut que cette
immunité puisse rester à un haut niveau
mars pour qu'elle reste très protectrice
des personnes concernées on parle de
personnes qui sont fragiles de par leur
âge ou de par des maladies qu'elles
connaissent par ailleurs à date sur une
population éligible de 4,5 millions de
personnes c'est donc avant ce que je
vous ai annoncé sur les soignants
environ 1.5 million de personnes ont
déjà recouru au rappel c'est beaucoup et
encore une fois le rythme augmente je
crois que rien qui hier près de soixante
dix mille personnes ont bénéficié d'un
rappel vaccinal mais ce n'est pas encore
assez et donc il faut poursuivre
évidemment sur cette voie ce conseil des
ministres avait une importance
particulière aussi parce qu'il a été
l'occasion d'adopter le projet de loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale pour
2022 qui marque une nouvelle étape dans
notre action de protection toujours plus
forte des français depuis 18 mois la
sécurité sociale a permis aux français
de tenir malgré la crise sanitaire la
france est le pays où l'on a traversé la
crise en étant testé en étant soignés en
étant vacciner sans frais nous sortons
de cette crise la tête haute grâce au
choix que nous avons fait et à la
robustesse de notre système social ces
dépenses exceptionnelles ont représenté
15 milliards d'euros en 2021 et nous
prévoyons encore 5 milliards d'euros en
2022 nous les assumons évidemment ce
projet de loi c'est d'abord un texte de
conquête de conquête pour les jeunes
femmes et pour le droit à disposer
pleinement de son corps avec la gratuité
de la contraception pour toutes les
jeunes femmes jusqu'à 25 ans de conquête
pour les femmes seules pour les familles
monoparentales et pour les mères
célibataires en rendant automatique la
garantie contre les impayés de pension
alimentaire vous le savez pour toutes
ces femmes qui élèvent seules leurs
enfants dont le conjoint était
défaillant dans le versement de la
pension alimentaire nous avons mis en
place un système une garantie qui permet
à la caf de verser la pension
alimentaire et de se retourner ensuite
vers le conjoint défaillant pour le
remboursement c'est un système qui
fonctionnait entre guillemets à
l'inscription ce système avec le plfss
2022 devient automatique pour toutes les
femmes c'est un texte de conquête aussi
pour toutes celles et tous ceux qui
souffre de troubles psychologiques qui
ont besoin d'être aidés et qu'ils
verront désormais les consultations chez
les psychologues rembourser dès l'âge de
3 ans c'est un texte de conquête pour
les familles et pour les personnes âgées
en donnant corps à la cinquième branche
de la sécurité sociale dédiée à
l'autonomie cette branche qui avait été
tant de fois promise par les majorités
précédente que nous avons créé l'année
dernière que nous abondons donc avec ce
texte nous prenons des mesures pour les
aidants nous investissons massivement
pour le maintien à domicile et la
société change et chacun le droit de
vivre son âge dans la dignité c'est un
texte de conquête aussi pour notre
hôpital et pour nos ehpad nos maisons de
retraite avec une nouvelle étape majeure
du secteur de la santé et notamment des
revalorisations inédite des personnels
hospitaliers des ehpad et du secteur
médico social de nouvelles mesures
seront mises en oeuvre au profit des
plus bas salaires ou encore pour les
sages-femmes qui percevront cela a été
dit par olivier ferrand 360 euros nets
supplémentaires par mois au total il y
aura eu dans le ségur près de 10
milliards d'euros de revalorisation des
professionnels de santé soit la plus
grande hausse des salaires hospitalier
jamais réalisée et une des plus grandes
politiques sociales et féministe des
dernières décennies le séduire c'est
aussi le retour des investissements à
l'hôpital et dans les ehpad pour la
première année depuis bien longtemps
nous ne ferons pas d'économies sur
l'hôpital nous l'assumons près de 2
milliards d'euros de nouveaux
investissements seront déployés en 2021
pour rénover des services pour acquérir
des équipements pour renforcer la place
du numérique et pour améliorer le
quotidien des soignants comme des
patients nous investissons bien sûr pour
la solidarité et la santé mais nous
gardons le cap comme pour l'ensemble de
notre action ce plfss conjugue
l'ambition et la responsabilité la
confiance des français dans leur système
social repose en grande partie sur sa
soutenabilité financière et nous ne
l'avons jamais perdu de vue si nous
mettons forcément et si nous mettrons
forcément du temps à revenir à
l'équilibré nous amorçons dès cette
année une trajectoire de nette
diminution du déficit qui sera de 21 6
milliards d'euros en 2022 contre 35
milliards en 2021 en matière de
solidarité je veux insister sur le
rapport économique social et financier
qui a été publiée cette semaine et qui a
souligné les efforts de notre politique
économique pour les personnes les moins
favorisés il a été relayé par un certain
nombre de médias évidemment j'invite
celles et ceux qui sont intéressés à le
consulter le président de la république
a également profité de ce conseil des
ministres pour revenir sur une ambition
importante de ce quinquennat prendre des
marges de manoeuvre aux français et
faire en sorte que le travail paye nous
sommes le quinquennat qui a inversé la
courbe des prélèvements obligatoires est
rendue plus de 50 milliards d'impôt aux
ménages et aux entreprises dans notre
pays
suppression de la taxe d'habitation pour
80% des ménages baisse des cotisations
sociales baisse de l'impôt sur le revenu
pour les premières tranches baisse de
l'impôt sur les sociétés et des impôts
de production avec nous les taxes sont à
la baisse avec nous les feuilles d'impôt
s'allège et ce sont plus de 50 milliards
d'euros à nouveau que nous avons
redistribué aux français et à l'économie
nous sommes aussi le quinquennat qui a
récompensé le travail et donner de l'air
aux classes moyennes entre les baisses
de cotisations et l'augmentation de la
prime d'activité les français au smic
sont parmi les premiers bénéficiaires de
notre action nous avons permis à leur
revenu d'augmenter de 170 euros net par
mois c'est une hausse inédite à laquelle
il faut ajouter évidemment les
revalorisations sur le quinquennat du
smic qui on est et qui ont été annoncés
la dernière en date évidemment du 1er
octobre tout cumulé nous avons ainsi
donner un 13e mois et près d'un
quatorzième mois à toutes celles et à
tous ceux qui travaille au smic nous
avons ainsi porté leur revenu net à 1464
euros nets ce que beaucoup promettaient
ce que certains promettent encore nous
l'avons fait évidemment cet
investissement et ce travail se poursuit
et va se poursuivre faire en sorte que
le travail paye c'est aussi ne reculer
devant aucune réforme la réforme de
l'assurance chômage qui est entrée en
application la semaine dernière en est
une preuve on peut agir avec courage et
détermination
on peut casser la spirale de la
précarité et garantir aux français ou
français qu'on touchera toujours plus en
travaillant caen ne travaillant pas
c'est le sens de cette réforme enfin son
quinquennat est celui qui a permis de ne
laisser personne au bord du chemin les
plus précaires les plus exposés les plus
en difficulté ont été au coeur de chacun
de nos combats plusieurs minima sociaux
ont connu sous ce quinquennat des
revalorisations inédite je pensais à
l'allocation adulte handicapé et à
l'allocation de solidarité aux personnes
âgées qui ont augmenté de près de 100
euros nets mensuels de même nous avons
généralisé et revaloriser le chèque
énergie pour 6 millions de français on
peut enfin citer les retraites agricoles
les plus faibles puisque nous avons
traduit concrètement notre engagement de
revalorisation de ces retraites
agricoles on parle de personnes qui ont
travaillé toute leur vie qui ont
travaillé dur qui percevaient des
retraites très faible et nous avons mis
un plancher minimales au dessus de 1000
euros s'était demandé par beaucoup
s'étaient d'ailleurs demandé par des
propositions de loi qui avait été porté
par les communistes le groupe communiste
à l'assemblée nationale que nous avons
adoptée en ce sens faire en sorte que le
travail paye donner des opportunités à
chacun voilà notre bilan voilà ce que
nous avions promis et que nous avons
engagée voilà ce qui permet à chacun de
pouvoir prendre pleinement son destin en
mains de choisir sa vie de s'émanciper
c'est évidemment un travail qui va se
poursuivre et c'est évidemment aussi
l'action que nous avons menée depuis
2010 est au ministère du travail et dont
elisabeth bornes nous a rappelé le bilan
ce matin puisqu'elle présentait le bilan
des réformes prioritaires de son
ministère vous savez qu'il ya une partie
du conseil des ministres qui est dédié à
la présentation des réformes
prioritaires de chacun des ministères et
aujourd'hui c'est la ministre du travail
et de l'insertion elisabeth banques qui
présentait son action l'activité
partielle à protéger jusqu'à 9 millions
de salariés au plus fort de la crise et
l'activité partielle de longue durée est
un bouclier pour l'emploi des secteurs
qui continuent à subir les conséquences
de la crise dix-huit mille
établissements et 1,2 million de
salariés en bénéficient encore nous
avons remis les jeunes sur le chemin de
l'emploi et de l'insertion grâce au plan
un jeune une solution 2 2 millions de
jeunes de moins de 26 ans ont pu signer
un cdi ou un cdd long et 550 mille
contrats d'apprentissage ont été conclus
un niveau encore une fois historique
nous avions déjà battu le record l'an
dernier nous leur bâton
cette année grâce à notre soutien massif
c'est un record et c'est ce qui a aussi
permis une nette baisse du chômage des
jeunes au trimestre dernier nous nous
sommes engagés contre le recours abusif
aux travailleurs détachés 12500
contrôles ont eu lieu l'année dernière
déjà près de 12000 cette année nous
sommes déterminés à garantir à chacun
des conditions de travail dignes et à
faire en sorte que les entreprises
puissent se tourner vers d'autres
solutions pour leurs besoins de main
d'oeuvre mesdames et messieurs ce
conseil a également été l'opportunité
d'adopter plusieurs textes sur lesquels
je reviens très rapidement le ministre
des solidarités et de la santé a
présenté un projet de loi ratifiant une
ordonnance relative à la certification
périodique de certains professionnels de
santé cette procédure qui garantit la
qualité des pratiques professionnelles
sera obligatoirement effectuer tous les
six ans à partir du 1er janvier 2023 le
ministre de l'économie des finances et
de la relance a présenté un projet de
loi ratifiant une ordonnance qui
transpose une directive européenne
cette directive qui permet de nouveaux
échanges d'informations financières à
des fins de lutte contre les infractions
ces dispositions constituent une avancée
notable en matière de lutte contre la
criminalité et par là une nouvelle
réalisation concrète de l'union qui
protège la ministre de la cohésion des
territoires et des relations avec les
collectivités territoriales enfin a
présenté une ordonnance réformant les
règles de publicité d'entrer en vigueur
et de conservation des actes pris par
les collectivités locales cette
ordonnance prend notamment plusieurs
mesures qui permettent de renforcer de
simplifier l'accès des citoyens à une
information locale claire utile tant en
matière de démocratie que d'urbanisme
c'est une disposition qui fait suite à
la loi engagement et proximité qui avait
été adoptée durant ce quinquennat enfin
pour terminer alors que la conférence
des familles s'est achevé hier olivier
ferrand et adrien paquet ont présenté
une communication sur les 1000 premiers
jours de l'enfant et sur les suites de
la conférence des familles ainsi les
ministres ont plus rappelé les avancées
majeures réalisées pendant ce
quinquennat d'abord l'obligation dans
l'entretien prénatal précoce pour les
mères en début de grossesse et vous le
savez la mise en place dès 2022 d'un
entretien post natale pour lutter contre
la dépression post partum conformément à
l' annonce du président de la république
il y a quelques semaines cela entrera en
vigueur dès 2022 ensuite la création de
postes de en maternité et un
renforcement des investissements de
l'état je vous donne un exemple 100
millions d'euros supplémentaires dans
les pmi les protection maternelle
infantile qui sont gérés par les
départements ces 100 millions d'euros
c'est l'équivalent des baisses de moyens
publics qu'elles ont subi sur ces dix
dernières années nous compensons en
trois ans la baisse des moyens pour les
pmi qui a été vécu pendant dix ans
ensuite le doublement du congé paternité
qui passe de deux semaines à un mois et
qui bénéficiera à 600000 perd chaque
année vous savez que la disposition est
entré en vigueur cette année un plan de
formation pour les 600 mille
professionnels de la petite enfance une
revalorisation de 30% du complément mode
de garde pour les 90 mille familles
monoparentales bref agir et accompagnés
chacun à tous les âges c'était un peu le
fil rouge de ce conseil des ministres je
me tiens maintenant à votre disposition
pour répondre à vos questions
camille klein est ensuite
allé à berthelot mais
j'ai deux questions sur le volet
sanitaire la première tout à l'heure
vous disiez que l'heure n'était pas
encore arrivé de lever toutes les
mesures est ce que vous discutez quand
même au gouvernement un allègement du
contrôle du pass à lithaire le moment
venu quand on pourra alléger ses
contrôles comment ça va se faire est ce
que ce sera de manière territorialisée
ou par secteur et puis deuxième question
sur la dose de rappel pour les soignants
la troisième dose est ce qu'elle est
obligatoire aussi pour les soignants
comme le sont les deux premières doses
alors sur le premier point je redis ce
que j'ai toujours eu l'habitude de dire
dès lors que nous pouvons nous
débarrasser d'une contrainte nous le
faisons
confère ce que nous faisons alors sa
démarche mais ce que nous faisons sur le
masque pour les plus jeunes enfants à
l'école dans un nombre de plus en plus
important de département la majorité de
départements à partir de la semaine
prochaine dès lors que nous avons des
avis scientifiques qui nous disent que
l'on peut avancer en réduisant les
contraintes évidemment que nous le
faisons et pour les contraintes qui
restent qui sont évidemment beaucoup
moins importante que celle que notre
pays a pu connaître
sur ces 18 derniers mois l'inconnue
déconfinement on a connu des couvre-feux
on a connu des fermetures de secteurs
entiers de notre économie et de lieux où
les français avaient l'habitude de se
retrouver on n'est plus dans cette
situation là aujourd'hui nous avons un
passé annie terre qui au contraire nous
a permis de maintenir tous ces lieux
ouverts et de ne pas prendre prendre ces
mesures cet été au coeur d'une quatrième
vague dont on voyait des taux
d'incidence extrêmement extrêmement
élevé mais évidemment que dès lors que
nous considérons et que les
scientifiques nous dirons que c'est
possible et que ses responsables et que
c'est sans risque évidemment que nous
continuerons à alléger les mesures ni le
pass sanitaires ni le masque ni aucune
autre mesure qui existe aujourd'hui ne
sont éternels et dès lors qu'on pourra
les réduire évidemment que nous le
ferons s'agissant du pass sanitaire vous
le savez nous avons demandé un avis au
conseil scientifique qui nous a remis je
crois hier et donc qui a pu être
présenté ce matin en conseil de défense
c'est un avis qui nous appelle à une
certaine prudence parce que je le disais
nous rentrons dans la période hivernale
et nous savons que à cette occasion
l'épidémie peut repartir c'est ce que
nous constatons malheureusement dans un
certain nombre de pays de l'est où on
voit l'épidémie qui repart c'est aussi
souvent liée à une faible couverture
vaccinale dans ces pays nous avons la
chance d'avoir une couverture vaccinale
très importante en france que nous
cherchons à renforcer avec le rappelle
je vous le disais à l'instant mais nous
regardons ce avec beaucoup d'attention
si adaptation du pass il devait y avoir
elle ne saurait donc être envisagé avant
le 15 novembre
pour répondre à tes pas votre deuxième
question on va dire la question 1 bis
puisque c'était une partie de votre
première question sur ce que pourrait
être cette adaptation j'ai pas d'annoncé
à faire puisque nous réfléchissons en ce
moment évidemment nous regardons les
différents scénarios ce que je peux vous
dire à date en toute transparence ça
évoluera peut-être dans les semaines à
venir puisque je vous ai indiqué qu'il
n'y aurait pas d'adaptation en tout cas
en tout état de cause avant cette
échéance de la mi-novembre dans ce que
nous regardons c'est d'ailleurs plutôt
ce que recommande le conseil
scientifique dans son avis c'est plutôt
des décisions d'ordre national
et probablement plutôt des décisions par
secteur certains secteurs qui pourraient
voir une adaptation du passé sanitaire
mais c'est encore très tôt et donc je
peux pas vous en dire davantage
aujourd'hui évidemment dès lors qu'il y
aura des annonces nous le ferons sur la
deuxième question que vous avez posé sur
l'obligation du rappel pour les
soignants aujourd'hui n'y a pas
d'obligation du rappel je rappelle qu'on
a toujours fonctionné avec la même
méthode c'est avant tout la confiance et
la confiance dans la responsabilité des
français je vous ai dit aussi qu'il ya
énormément de soignants qui étaient en
demande de pouvoir procéder à ce rappel
donc louvre on permet évidemment aux
soignants d'y recourir et aujourd'hui il
n'y a pas d'autre annonce à faire sur ce
sujet là même si vous avez toujours
l'habitude de m'entendre dire sur le co
vite que je n'exclus jamais rien par
principe pour l'avenir et là aussi nous
suivrons évidemment de très près les
recommandations scientifiques qui
pourront nous être fait sur sur ce sujet
là
bonjour je rebondis sur la première
question de ma collègue pour vous la
tournée autrement dans la mesure où il
ya une soixantaine de départements qui
remplissent la condition que vous aviez
fixé qui était un taux d'incidence
inférieur à 50 dans ces départements
qu'est ce qui justifie que vous n'allez
gier pas les mesures sanitaires dans ces
territoires là en question pourquoi
attendre finalement le 15 novembre pour
prendre cette décision et puis une
question un peu plus politique sur un
autre sujet dans une enquête parue hier
eric zemmour est donné au deuxième tour
face à emmanuel macron est ce que c'est
devenu aujourd'hui votre adversaire
principal
sur la première question la réponse est
très claire jeu j'avais déjà eu
l'occasion de vous dire ici que quand on
réfléchit qu'on travaille sur des
adaptations du pass sanitaires on
regarde toutes choses le taux
d'incidence est là il ya effectivement
un critère de 50 pour cent mille
habitants qui est le seuil d alerte dans
notre pays on regarde aussi le niveau de
la couverture vaccinale ce qui est un
critère qu'on ne peut pas regarder par
définition quand on prend des mesures
concernent les jeunes enfants à l'école
primaire puisque la vaccination ne les
concerne pas et donc ces différents
critères qu'on regarde sur le critère de
couverture vaccinale c'est encore un
travail qui est mené des points qui
restent à affiner c'est la raison pour
laquelle les deux sujets ne sont pas
liés maintenant moi je veux dire aussi
que on ne ressent pas
d'attentes particulièrement forte autour
d'une urgence qu'il y aurait à
adapter ou alléger le pass sanitaire
aujourd'hui les français se sont emparés
de cet outil ils ont vu que cet outil
est extrêmement simple et les secteurs
concernés évidemment que sa demande un
petit travail supplémentaire les
secteurs concernés ont bien vu cet été
que le passé ni terre c'est ce qui nous
a permis de laisser ces secteurs ces
établissements ouverts alors même que
ces vies c'est une quatrième vague très
forte dans notre pays qui auraient pu
nous imposer de refermer ces lieux si on
n'avait pas disposer de cet outil
c'était la fin mais à part donc là vous
voyez je suis non mais je vais vous
redire ce que je veux vous redire ce que
j'ai l'habitude de vous dire
régulièrement sur ces sujets là quand
vous posez des questions d'ordre
politique au sens politicien au sens
élections moi je suis ici dans ma
fonction de porte parole du gouvernement
qui vous rend compte des discussions en
conseil des ministres on ne discute pas
en conseil des ministres des sujets des
élections on est concentré sur la
gestion de la crise sanitaire sur la
relance de notre économie sur le plan
d'investissements d'avenir à venir
france 2030 sur les réformes que nous
continuons à mener dans notre pays pour
les français donc je n'ai pas de
commentaire à faire sur ce sujet là je
ne fais ici ni commentaire politique
électorale ni d'ailleurs promotion
d'éditorialistes qui sont aujourd'hui
dans des campagnes de promotion de leurs
livres voilà je suis pas là pour faire
vendre des livres
bonjour monsieur le ministre à vis de ce
taxi pour canal+ ses news un autre sujet
on observe depuis quelques semaines une
recrudescence importante d'étudiants
lors des distributions alimentaires leur
part un euro il est désormais réservé
aux étudiants boursiers alors qu'ils
étaient accessibles avant à tous les
associations les alertes vraiment sûr
sur cette situation depuis début
septembre est ce que finalement la
situation des étudiants ce n'est plus la
priorité du gouvernement contraire vous
savez qu'on a pris des mesures
probablement comme aucun autre pays
pendant cette crise pour soutenir les
étudiants et lutter contre la précarité
étudiante
ça ne veut pas dire évidemment qu'il ne
reste pas des situations très difficiles
est ce qu'on cherche à faire aujourd'hui
c'est à répondre à ces situations
difficiles on a je crois doubler les
aides d'urgence dont disposent les
universités qui sont à la main des
universités pour accompagner les
étudiants qui sont dans la précarité
dans la difficulté vous l'avait indiqué
il ya des mesures qui s'appliquent pour
les étudiants boursiers notamment leurs
pains
euros au restaurant universitaire il
peut y avoir des étudiants qui ne sont
pas boursiers qui se retrouvent dans des
tissus dans des situations très
compliquées soit pour des raisons
factuelles pour des questions de rupture
familiale soit pour des raisons sur du
plus long terme et dans ces cas là le
temps qu'ils puissent bénéficier de la
bourse il peut y avoir des moments
difficiles et c'est pour ça qu'il ya ces
aides d'urgence qui sont à la main des
universités qui peuvent donner lieu à
plusieurs centaines d'euros versés
immédiatement ont versé sur du plus long
terme pour accompagner les étudiants on
constate souvent que ces aides ne sont
pas intégralement consommés ce qui
montre qu'il ya un problème
d'information probablement et donc votre
question permettent de remettre en avant
ces dispositifs qui existent et
évidemment d'inviter les étudiants
contactés les services sociaux de leurs
universités pour pouvoir être
accompagnés et évidemment on continue
aussi à soutenir les associations qui
s'engagent en faveur des étudiants et on
continuera toujours à travailler à des
mesures qui permettent de les
accompagner c'est ce que fait notamment
ma collègue frédéric vidal en lien avec
les organisations étudiantes
comment il ya des décisions qui ont été
prises dans le cadre de la crise
sanitaires
il ya potentiellement d'autres décisions
qui peuvent être prises si jamais nous
constatons que les difficultés se
poursuivent sur ce point-là collectif
abidal a l'habitude de s'exprimer sur ce
sujet là le fera à nouveau je rappelle
aussi que nous avons gelé les droits
d'inscription il ya des mesures que nous
prenons évidemment dès lors que nous
constituons considérons que c'est
nécessaire
oui bonjour elizabeth pineau de l'agencé
reuteurs j'ai deux questions une
première sur le différend sur la pêche
entre paris et londres sur les licences
de pêche la milice de la mère annick
girardin avait donné s'était donné 15
jours pour éventuellement décider de
mesures de rétorsion en avait appelé à
l'europe où en est-on de ces mesures
qu'elle pourrait l'être et à quelle date
nous travaillons à ces mesures vous avez
raison de rappeler l'échéance qui a été
donné par anidjar dans la semaine
dernière suite à cette décision tout
simplement inadmissible des autorités
britanniques qui ne respectent tout
simplement pas l'accord qui a été conclu
dans le cadre du brésil on a toujours
donné toutes les informations qu'on nous
demandait les professionnels les
pêcheurs qui encaisse quand même
beaucoup depuis le début de ce dossier
ont toujours fait preuve d'une très
grande responsabilité ont été patients
ont donné les informations qui leur
était demandé pour pouvoir bénéficier
des licences en face de ça nous avons
les autorités britanniques qui
manifestement ne veulent pas respecter
l'accord aujourd'hui tel qu'il a été
signé et donc ce que nous avions eu
l'occasion de vous dire c'est que nous
travaillons dans un cadre européen
puisque c'est la commission européenne
qui est compétente et que nous avons
demandé la réunion du conseil de
partenariat pour
avancer sur ces questions là pour
pouvoir prendre des mesures dès lors que
c'est nécessaire et que nous
réfléchissons aussi à des mesures
nationales il ya un horizon de temps qui
a été donnée donc j'espère que la
semaine prochaine je pourrai vous en
dire davantage sur ce sujet d'accorder
par avance et on n'a pas l'impression
que l'europe soit à fond sur ce sujet
vous dire qu'avec des échanges encore
récemment que président de la république
avec la présidente de la commission
européenne a eu l'occasion d'en échanger
en marge du sommet qui s'est tenu en
slovénie hier que les différents
ministres échangent avec la commission
européenne c'est le cas d'anne et jardin
c'est le cas de mon collègue clément
bonne aussi qui s'en est entretenu
encore hier avec le vice-président de la
commission chargé de ces sujets là donc
je peux vous dire qu'il ya une très
grande mobilisation côté français en
lien avec la commission européenne pour
avancer rapidement sur ce sujet qui n'a
que trop duré alors j'ai une deuxième
question concernant le nucléaire
est-ce que vous pouvez nous confirmer
qu'il emmanuel macron annoncera sans
doute la semaine prochaine dans le cadre
de l' annonce du plan d'investissement
la construction de ce qu'on appelle des
mini centrales nucléaires
de pire acteur modulaire nucléaire plus
faciles à fabriquer que des fois des
grandes centrales merci d'abord vous
l'avais dit dans votre question le
président la république s'exprimera
mardi prochain sur le plan
d'investissement sur france 2030 qui
vise à quoi qui vise à prendre un train
d'avancé dans un certain nombre de
secteurs et investir dans des secteurs
stratégiques qui seront les secteurs
pourvoyeurs de croissance et d'emploi
dans notre pays à horizon 10 ans les
secteurs aujourd'hui dans lesquelles il
ya un sous-investissement parce que pour
des acteurs privés d'investir dans ces
secteurs là cela peut coûter beaucoup
d'argent au début est évidemment
rapporté peu au début c'est là où notre
conception du rôle de l'état c'est de
pouvoir permettre cet amorçage et donc
de prendre de la faire prendre de
l'avancé à notre pays ensuite sur la
question du nucléaire car notre discours
est évidemment très clair nous croyons
au nucléaire nous croyons au nucléaire
parce qu'il permet une énergie
décarbonée je rappelle que la france est
un des pays d'europe si ce n'est le pays
d'europe qui produit le moins de tonnes
de co2 par habitant notamment grâce au
nucléaire et donc c'est un enjeu
environnemental très fort c'est aussi un
enjeu de pouvoir d'achat sont disposés
pas aujourd'hui du nucléaire dans le
contexte que nous connaissons avec la
flambée des prix de l'énergie la facture
d'électricité des français
augmenteraient énormément et c'est un
enjeu de souveraineté par ailleurs qui
nous permet d'être moins dépendant que
d'autres pays notamment certains de nos
voisins d'une énergie qui vient de pays
avec lesquels nous pouvons avoir des
relations difficiles nous croyons
nucléaire mme président a eu l'occasion
de dire à plusieurs reprises nous
investissons par ailleurs déjà dans le
cadre du plan de relance évidemment nous
allons poursuivre cet investissement
mais pour ce qui est du détail
et des chantiers sur lesquels nous
allons investir c'est évidemment le
président de la république qui
s'exprimera la semaine prochaine dans le
cadre de la présentation du plan france
2030 mais ses mimiques votre achat vous
semblera un bon compromis moi je vous ai
dit à l'instant notre vision du
nucléaire nôtres soient évidemment de
continuer à investir dans le nucléaire
pour les raisons que je vous ai évoqué
environnement pouvoir d'achat
indépendance de notre pays est par
ailleurs indépendance européenne qui ne
veut pas dire qu'on ne développe pas
aussi les énergies renouvelables parce
que c'est sain d'avoir différentes
ressources d'énergie mais le nucléaire
reste évidemment un client majeur de
notre stratégie énergétique
amine abdelmalek je suis au
correspondant de l'arabie est basé à
londres alors j'ai deux questions
au niveau international les relations
franco algériennes se dégrade
sensiblement
la bellière de mise à l'étrangère
monsieur lamamra a qualifié la fraude de
défaillances en matière de mémoire
qu en est il exactement
l'algérie style hippie vos dons au nord
de l'afrique avec l'étendue des
frontières de ses frontières à vic avec
le maghreb et l'afrique de l'ouest quel
est quelle est la situation réellement
aujourd'hui deuxième question se tiendra
demain à montpellier le sommet france
afrique
sont les chefs d'état africains quel est
le message que monsieur macro envoyé
effectivement ainsi pays merci sur le
premier point il ya eu
un certain nombre d'expressions côté
français votre président la république
du gouvernement j'ai pas de votre chose
à dire et évidemment notre souhait c'est
d'avoir une relation franche directe et
apaisée avec nos amis algériens et donc
je ne peux pas répondre ici à des propos
qui ont été tenus par un membre du
gouvernement
hier précisément parce que nous sommes
dans ce souhait d'apaisement et par
ailleurs mon collègue jean yves le drian
régulièrement l'occasion de s'exprimer
sur ce sujet là sur le sommet qui se
tiendra à montpellier vendredi
effectivement c'est un sommet qui se
tient non pas avec les chefs d'état et
de gouvernement mais avec la société
civile ce qui est un point qui nous
tient extrêmement hackers qui est dans
la lignée du discours qu'il avait
prononcé le président de la république à
ouagadougou qui était un discours
extrêmement important sur nos relations
avec nos partenaires africains et
évidemment le message le président de la
république aurait un message très fort à
cette occasion autour des grandes
priorités qui sont les nôtres évidemment
le développement évidemment l'éducation
notamment notre priorité sur l'éducation
des jeunes filles mais l'éducation en
général et l'émancipation de la jeunesse
africaine
audrey tease en france info la question
de la dea conjugale isation de
l'allocation adulte handicapé est revenu
à l'assemblée nationale ce matin proposé
cette fois par les républicains votre
majorité s'y oppose de nouveau pourquoi
nous avons aujourd'hui un système social
et fiscal qui est basé autour de la
conjugalité à sion et de la familia
lisation terme patrese n'est pas très
évident mais c'est aujourd'hui ça les
grands principes de notre système on
peut envisager de revenir sur ces
principes à ce moment là ça peut être un
débat d c'est un débat qui est
transversal qui est globale pour
l'ensemble de nos prestations sociales y
compris pour notre fiscalité ce débat
peut se tenir sur la question
l'allocation adulte handicapé comme des
personnes en situation de handicap d'une
manière générale et de notre politique
pour les personnes en situation de
handicap nous avons un investissement
très fort c'est l'une des grandes causes
de ce quinquennat je vais pas revenir
sur tout ce qui est fait pour l'accueil
des enfants en situation de handicap à
l'école sur la question de la hache ce
que je peux ce sur quoi je peux revenir
je les fais dans mon intervention
liminaire c'est sur le fait que nous
avons revaloriser l'allocation adulte
handicapé 200 euros nets par mois et une
revalorisation
massive et que pour continuer à soutenir
les personnes en situation de handicap
qui vivent dans un foyer qui connaît des
difficultés financières nous avons fait
le choix plutôt que cette proposition de
loi de passer par un autre mécanisme qui
fait partie du budget pour 2022 qui sera
discuté au parlement qui sera on
l'espère adopté qui consiste en un
abattement forfaitaire de 5000 euros sur
les revenus du conjoint c'est donc un
gain en moyenne de 110 euros mensuels
pour cent vingt mille couples concernés
à partir du 1er janvier évidemment nous
continuons à investir et à agir pour les
personnes en situation de handicap et
pour leurs ressources et leurs revenus
dans notre pays
j'ai une autre question par rapport à la
date anniversaire de la mort de samuel
pâtit est ce qu'on peut savoir ce qui se
prépare notamment dans les écoles et
est-ce que éventuellement la famille
sa mère pattie va être reçue par les
autorités par monsieur macron
oui nous commémorons en fin de semaine
prochaine
un an après
la mort tragique l'attentât terrible qui
a été père près de perpétrer la mort de
samuel pâtit évidemment ce sera
l'occasion dans l'ensemble de nos
établissements scolaires
la journée de vendredi prochain d'avoir
un temps dommage et le président de la
république recevra le samedi la famille
de samuel pâtit
sylvie corbet associative presse c'est
une question suite à la remise du
rapport de jean marc sauvé sur les abus
sexuels dans l'église le président de la
conférence des évêques a indiqué que le
secret de la confession étaient plus
forts que les lois de la république
d'abord est ce qu'elle est la réaction
du gouvernement à ça et plus
généralement suite à la remise de ce
rapport est ce que l'état peut faire
quelque chose
pour voilà travailler avec l'église pour
appliquer les recommandations du rapport
la réaction à ses propos elle est très
claire il n'y a rien de plus fort que
les lois de la république
dans notre pays ça tient en une phrase
et c'est très clair le président la
république a demandé au ministre de
l'intérieur de recevoir le président de
la conférence des évêques de france pour
que les choses soient claires de ce
point de vue là et les changera lieu je
crois la semaine prochaine pour ce qui
est du rapport évidemment moi je veux
saluer le travail qui a été fait dire
évidemment
immédiatement que le première pensée
elle vaut évidemment pour les victimes
des très nombreuses victimes
et qu'il y a à l'évidence un travail
qu'il faut continuer de mener et que
l'état évidemment présents pour
accompagner dès lors que c'est
nécessaire celles et ceux qui mènent ce
travail comme nous menons évidemment
aussi dans nos institutions
bonjour pour rejoindre la question de
mon confrère sur les relations avec
l'algérie il va y avoir une prise de
parole pour commémorer la manifestation
du 17 octobre 1961
est-ce que vous pouvez nous dire un
petit peu ce qui peut être dit à cette
occasion
vous en dire plus pour l'instant il ya
effectivement cette commémoration mais
je peux pas vous donner plus
d'informations ni sur le cadre sur la
manière dont ça va se dérouler à ce
stade
c'était la semaine prochaine puisque ce
ne serait pas encore repasser
une question d'actualité
eric de moulins beaufort donc qui
représente les évêques de france
apparemment être convoqué par gérald
darmanin
juste une précision à vous demander sur
la question des tests qui vont être
déremboursés à partir de la semaine
prochaine est-ce que vous pouvez nous
confirmer les montants qui ont été donné
ce matin et nous redire peut-être dans
quelles conditions ces tests ne seront
plus pris en charge finalement par
l'assurance maladie
alors nous avons décidé qu'à compter du
15 octobre
les tests ne continuerait à être
remboursés
plus tôt je veux faire dans l'autre sens
les textes nous avons décidé qu'à partir
du 15 octobre les tests ne seraient plus
remboursés
pour les majeurs non vaccinés qui ne
bénéficient pas d'une prescription
médicale ou qui ne sont pas signalés
qu'à contacter par l'assurance maladie
voilà les personnes qui sont concernées
le sens de cette mesure c'est quoi c'est
de dire que les impôts et les
cotisations des français n'ont pas à
financer des tests qui sont utilisés
comme un vaccin de substitution par des
personnes qui ont fait le choix de ne
pas se faire vacciner un test n'est pas
un vaccin de substitution et certains
utilisent le recours massif aux tests
pour pouvoir bénéficier du pass
sanitaires pour accéder à un certain
nombre d'activités parce qu'ils ont fait
le choix de ne pas se faire vacciner ce
n'est pas à la collectivité aux français
de financer ce choix donc la mesure va
s'appliquer sur le tarif j'ai vu les
informations les chiffres qui ont été
évoqués dans la presse je vous confirme
que c'est bien dans cet ordre là
alité ça dépendra du lieu et du jour où
le test est réalisé en gros le principe
c'est quoi c'est que ce qui sera facturé
c'est ce que ça coûte à l'assurance
maladie et donc je vous donne un exemple
si vous faites un test antigénique dans
un laboratoire de biologie médicale ces
22 euros en réalité la très grande
majorité des tests antigénique sont
réalisés en pharmacie aujourd'hui je
crois que c'est 80% en pharmacie ses 25
euros si c'est le dimanche parce que ça
coûte un peu plus cher à l'assurance
maladie ce sera 30 euros et pour les
tests pcr c'est autour de 44 euros je
crois par tous donc voilà c'est les prix
qui ont été communiquées c'est ce que ça
coûte à l'assurance maladie donc c'est
normal que ce soit ce que nous facturons
aux personnes qui vont se faire tester
qui ne correspondent pas aux critères
que j'évoquais à l'instant c'est à dire
être vaccinés être qu'à contacter ou
être mineure
pour avoir une ordonnance
s'il n'y a pas d'autres questions je
vous remercie
je vous dis à la semaine prochaine